[Music]
welcome to just the facts with your
personal guide of clarity through this
clouded miasma we call life J jonah
Jameson folks for all of you who've
called in praising the work of
spider-man let me point something for
all the so-called good he does the only
thing he never seems to be able to do is
finish the job I know you've heard the
rumors the black cat and some sort of
mechanized version of hammerhead are
both still rampaging through the streets
because the masked vigilante you call a
hero failed to stop them and if you
haven't had enough mayhem on your daily
commute in comes the international
mercenary known as silver sable riding
along on a giant hovercraft as if
traffic isn't bad enough already wait
you might be wondering if spider-man
couldn't stop one of these freaks how is
he gonna take down all three at the same
time great question
probably the same way he always does
swinging around wild ribbing people in
the face and dressing up in different
costumes because that's literally all he
knows how to do
spider-man listen up if you can't put
away your toys let the adult step in and
handle it because this city can't take
any more of your theatrics
these are stop the crime you're
indirectly causing or crawl back to your
fly infested web and that's the final
word with me the only voice of reason in
a world gone mad J Tony James
[Music]
please